notre invité ce soir éric tétreault qui
est le président de l'association de
l'énergie du québec bonsoir monsieur
tetrobot choix monsieur fillion est ce
que la défense des pipelines par justin
trudeau et erin auto c'est de la belle
musique à vos oreilles mais c'est à dire
qu'on peut pas mieux s'exprimer que l'on
fait le premier ministre et le chef
conservateur nous sommes dans un monde
où la transition énergétique sera lente
chacun sait que les infrastructures
n'ont pas été bâti pour autre chose que
les hydrocarbures alors il faudra
prendre le temps de le faire ce qu'il
s'agit de faire en fait c'est de prendre
les bonnes décisions aujourd'hui plutôt
que de prendre des décisions qui sont
dictés par l'urgence ou par un
quelconque calendrier politique mais
quand vous parlez de l'urgence l'urgence
climatique pourrait dicter qu'on arrête
d'en construire des pipelines et au
contraire monsieur trudeau et o'toole
vont de l'avant monsieur autour parle
même de relancer le projet northern
gateway est ce qu'on doit faire ça c'est
à dire que ce que les chefs politiques
se trouve à dire c'est que ya encore une
forte demande pour le pétrole et pour le
gaz naturel dans le monde alors si le
canada ne répond pas ça demande
quelqu'un d'autre quelque part sur la
planète ne fera nommément la chine la
russie qui tentent de prendre davantage
de marchés en europe alors ayons peut
pas arrêter ce mouvement alors on ne
peut pas battre marché avec des
politiques alors il faut être réaliste
un certain moment donné c'est la raison
pour laquelle le gouvernement du canada
avait acheté trois ans ma télé cherchent
évidemment le plus rapidement possible
de redonner au secteur privé parce qu'il
ya un marché est ce que est ce que
d'être réaliste c'est aussi de constater
qui a fait 50 degrés celsius un certain
moment de l'été dans l'ouest canadien
qui a tout un village qui est passé au
feu qu'on a eu des canicules que le
réchauffement climatique qui lie les
pires scénarios qu'on envisage semble
déjà se produire est-ce que d'être
réaliste ce serait pas d'arrêter de
développer l'industrie ben oui mais
venez avec moi essayer de convaincre le
président chinois le président russe et
le président indien de cesser de
recourir aux hydrocarbures on voyait
bien que ce n'est pas jouable
chez nous oui bah c'est sûr on a une
responsabilité j'ai une bonne nouvelle
pour vous on a le canada émet 1,6 pour
cent à peine 2 des émissions mondiales
c'est très peu mais oui il faut jouer
notre rôle et oui il faut être
exemplaire et puisque monsieur fillion
vous met vite et toujours au bon moment
aujourd'hui je reviens d'une conférence
dans l'ouest canadien avec une bonne
nouvelle pour vous si je crois qu'il va
se construire d'autres pipeline en
amérique du nord aux états unis au
canada mais certainement pas pour
transporter davantage de pétrole et de
gaz naturel qui de mieux que les du ce
cri pour capturer le carbone de
séquestrer le stocker sous terre
c'est un produit que l'industrie connaît
par coeur et c'est une industrie qui a
les moyens de faire actuellement et qui
se fait dire constamment par les marchés
et paroisse suite qu'il faut accélérer
la transition la conférence qui a eu
lieu en alberta a été un tournant pour
l'industrie en fin de semaine c'est là
qu'on a vu les acteurs majeurs de
l'industrie se positionner très
fermement dans la capture et le retrait
de ces émissions la de l'atmosphère et
je suis convaincu que c'est la façon la
plus rapide et la plus efficace de
baisser drastiquement nos émissions mais
est-ce que c'est pas tout simplement la
solution qui permettrait de continuer à
produire et même d'augmenter la
production et de passer à côté de
l'enjeu qui serait celui de la
transition énergétique
non tant le carbone on a fait pas la
transition énergétique de se dire qu'on
l'a fait rapidement on capte ce carbone
non mais si on ne produit pas quelqu'un
d'autre ailleurs sur la planète va enfin
ce qu'il s'agit de faire c'est
convaincre les dirigeants mondiaux qui
ne sont pas sur la sur la voie que le
canada et le québec ont choisi s'agit de
convaincre ces gens là de cesser de
recourir le plus rapidement possible aux
hydrocarbures mais les signaux qu'on a
de la russie de la chine vont pas dans
ce sens on est là on est à 0,1 pour cent
0,1 pour cent de toutes nos émissions de
carbone de co2 dans l'industrie
pétrolière gazière du monde 0,1 pour
cent capter et là on travaille sur un
projet de 15 millions au canada sur 200
millions et on est loin du compte quand
même en termes de technologie de capture
captage car base c'est absolument
certain qu'on est loin du compte je suis
sûr que vous en avez fait l'analyse mais
on est aussi très loin du compte avec le
solaire et l'éolien qui même s'ils
coûtent moins chers vont nécessiter des
investissements faramineux pour des
marchés qui sont incertains alors on est
à l'époque je pense où il faut tout
essayer et l'industrie va se positionner
la tasse que le captage de carbone n'est
pas aussi incertain je vous fais la
promesse que ça va aller plus rapidement
que tout ce qui est décidé politiquement
sur la table dans les dix prochaines
années pourquoi vous êtes soeur parce
que l'industrie connaît son produit et
qu'elle a les moyens de le faire elle
sait exactement ce qu'il faut faire et
l'industrie aux états unis à l'ecoute du
président baré donné nous avons des
côtes du gouvernement qui est très
sérieux vous l'avez dit d'entrée de jeu
le gouvernement de participer
financièrement il veut inciter
l'industrie pétrolière et gazière à se
transformer et quoi de mieux pour
l'alberta et l'économie canadienne que
de le faire le plus rapidement possible
est ce que le projet énergie est est
vraiment mort et enterré caen et rennes
au taux d'il y aura pas de pipeline au
québec selon moi oui c'était déjà le cas
je pense que monsieur o'toole vient
vient de dénoncer une vérité que
l'industrie connaît depuis déjà quelques
temps il y aura pas de projet pour ça il
n'y a pas de marché pour ça actuellement
il y en a pas davantage depuis que qui
se tourne avec celle a été rayée de la
carte par le président baril donnent il
faut jouer avec la demande heureusement
la ligne 3 and bridges ça va bien on
sent que les tribunaux et coûtent de
moins en moins des opposants la
gouverneure du michigan est de moins en
moins visible ce que nous avons nous
comme informations de nos collègues
américains c'est que le président
américain souhaitait ce projet là pour
le canada il ya quand même des limites à
stopper l'économie canadienne alors tant
que nous avons les projets qui sont sur
la table qui vont de l'avant ça va bien
aller pour le canada merci monsieur
tétreault d'avoir été avec nous et merci
monsieur fils ont toujours un plaisir au
revoir pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne i hier d